I think there's two main things that teachers are responsible for,...
...one of those things is obviously getting the material across to your students.
I think the second thing that's just as important is helping these students...
...and these kids grow up to be young adults.
Teaching them those life skills and those life lessons.
The role of a teacher in a student's life is actually get them to be problem solvers.
I think the content is important but I think they need to learn how to solve problems.
History's a story.
And if you can get them hooked on the story and how all the pieces and puzzle parts fit together...
...then they're gonna be interested in it.
My favorite teachers are great at making the content in class relatable...
...and making it applicable to the real world.
A secret weapon that I use is to use hands-on activities...
...to get the students engaged by actually being a part of the lesson and taking ownership to it.
A great teacher interacts with the students.
I think the role of a teacher in a student's life is to inspire them to be a lifelong learner.
I can teach you the strategies of reading the book.
I can teach you the strategies of how to write.
I can teach the problem solving strategies of tackling multiple choice questions...
...but ultimately you're the one doing it.
I think one thing that is crucial is developing relationships with your students.
That they can rely on you when they have an issue with material,...
...or when they have an issue at home or when they have an issue whatever.
I think the relationship that you build with your students is very important.
I think it's the most key in really kind of getting them to be comfortable in taking those risks.
You have to take an interest in your students...
...and what their lives are like, and what their interests are.
From when the school day ends until when they come back into your room the next day.
The great teachers are the ones...
...who are engaged in their job and their students' lives 24 hours a day.
Knowing your students, respecting them, knowing that they have lives outside of school,...
...trying to learn a little bit about that and also just setting those goals high...
...and helping them to meet them.
More than just the cognitive piece of that child,...
...I want to know them socially, emotionally and academically.
To really know them and to be present...
...and to challenge them to do a little bit more than they think they can do.
The great teacher I think makes connections with people...
...and realizes that it's not the subject matter at all but that we're all learners.